i'm sure you've heard weinstein say that
maybe we shouldn't be quantizing gravity
that we should be geometrizing the
quantum
have you taken a look at geometric unity
i have i have taken a a deep look at it
yes
okay what are your thoughts
well i do well you know i think well
there's it's um the mathematics is
definitely very you know very um
um advanced
um
[Music]
i think i think i think it's a beautiful
idea actually i think it's a really nice
idea the idea that i don't know what the
word is but you have you start off with
four dimensions the lorentz group and
then you do this you
you you think of all the components all
the ten components um in this four
dimensional world
um
you let that vary so therefore you have
a bundle structure like a fiber and all
these components are now a fiber fiber
over this four dimensional space
and that somehow
then gives you
um
the something that starts looking like a
grand unified group maybe it's so 10 or
something like that
so the 10 components of this fiber is
like m4 fiber dover it's so 10 maybe
again i'm bastardizing eric's idea but
sure i like this idea that somehow
you just start with that data and then
then you the mathematics just naturally
gives you this extra gauge structure
that seems to have embedded understand a
while now the devil's in the details and
i know that there are some criticisms
that need to be ironed out but i think
that's kind of what we do when we do
do when we do good theory you put it out
you give it your best shot
you know and especially if you're doing
it alone
um i think that
then others jump in and then they they
improve it or they
they find a mistake that's that's
actually that's what that's actually
what the refereeing profit process is
anyway any paper that i write
right well the first thing is i write
the paper or i work it out i do
something i get far enough where i feel
confident i have something but there's
always time places where i have blind
spots i give a seminar and the seminar
is usually where i get feedback before i
put the paper out then i put the paper
out
and then i put up for publication and
then usually the referees the referees
further help me um
understand what's going on actually and
if they find a bad
that is not publishable fine i learned
something new i move on uh that's
happened to me many times so i think
that
you know um
that component is missing
i think that component is he yeah i
think that component is um
is missing
precisely because you know eric is um
you know sort of going out a lot of this
alone
and um i encourage him he put it out and
i think that people should read it and
take it very seriously and and and play
with it and um and scrutinize it and i
think that there might be some gems in
there okay even if it's not it doesn't
turn out to pan out to be correct in you
know um
in terms of what it's
what it's trying to solve which is
unifying the standard model with general
relativity in this new way
at the very least for me at least i i'm
reading it or i've read it so that i can
learn some things and i'm definitely
i've definitely learned some interesting
things and it got me thinking about
um unification in in different ways now
so it's been it's valuable we should
have more of that
have you read wolfram's paper or
wolfram's physics project
um a little bit not i didn't you know
the answer is
i intend to i intend to when i have more
of some time yeah
i do know that it does it is related to
some ideas and
graph theory i also think that again
it's a it's um some nice ideas out there
it may strike some resonance with other
things like matrix theories and other
approaches
um
but i'm all one for let's populate
the the theory landscape with ideas and
let's scrutinize it and learn from it